[موسيقى]
اريد فقط ان اذكر انه بعدما
بعدما اني
ربحت كل القضايا قلت يجب ان اكشف للشعاب
التونسي ويجب ان يتم التتبع المتورطين
وقمت بايداع شيكايه رسميه في ملف التصوير
للنيابه العسكريه التي هي فتحت الملف عبر
تحويل الى قطب الارهاب وبدات الابحاث الى
ان وصلنا الى الحال هذايا
[موسيقى]
الراس المبدل الراس المدبر في ملف التسفير
اعتبر انه هناك العديد من الرؤوس لكن
اعتقد انه هناك شراره بدات من السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه منصف المرزوقي في ذلك الوقت
بانعقاد مؤتمر اصدقاء سوريا في تونس
كان ذلك الارضيه التي بدات بتسهيل ولا
بتقنين او باعطاء الضوء الاخضر
للتسفير لكن اعتبر انه راشد الغنوشي هو
الراس المدبر لكل تلك القضايا التي تهم
امن الدوله في تونس وهي وهو اول
المتورطين واول الاشخاص الذي اتهمهم
وكل
المعطيات تتوجه نحو في تسهيل ولا في
المتهمين من حركه الرئيس حركه النهضه
انذاك راشد الغنوشي او حتى المنصف المرزوق
يعني كرئيس لدوله تونس الجديده بعد الثوره
ان يسهل تسفير الالاف من الشباب التونسي
ليشارك في بؤر الارهاب في مناطق العالم
مختلف
كلهم متورطون وانا اعتقد انهم
متورطون بالعماله الى الخارج يعني انه
كانت همهم ارضاء
محاور معينه ارضاء بعض البلدان وذلك على
حساب ارواح التونسيين وشباب تونس